nach der türkischen grenze öffnung
griechenland bittet die eu um hilfe die
will eine neue flüchtlingskrise
verhindern
die frage nach der macht bei einer
strategiekonferenz streitet die
linkspartei darüber ob sie auch im bund
mitregieren will was im stadion
nach erneuten schmeckt's ionen
vermeintlicher fans gegen fußball mit
zehn hopp will die liga hart
durchgreifen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag mit
norbert könig für den sport natürlich
auch sportlichen erfolgen und nimmt die
alles beherrschende frage in europa
lautet derzeit wie umgehen mit einem
zustrom neuer flüchtlinge die türkei
setzt ihre militäroffensive in syrien
ford gleichzeitig lässt sie geflüchtete
ungehindert gen europa ziehen
doch nicht nur die kennen sie doch nur
die grenze auf türkischer seite ist
offen die griechen drängen die
flüchtlinge mit tränengas und
schlagstöcken zurück dominik
löschmeister sie harren aus dem
grenzgebiet zwischen der türkei und
griechenland mehr als 13.000 flüchtlinge
sollen es sein nach un-angaben die
griechische polizei drängt die menschen
zurück wir sehen dass die türkische
grenze geöffnet ist die griechische aber
ist geschlossen und sie setzten
tränengas ein
auch über den grenzfluss evros versuchen
sie nach griechenland zu gelangen
die griechische polizei verhinderte nach
eigenen angaben 10.000 versuchte
illegale grenzübertritte diejenigen die
griechisches territorium betreten haben
wurden festgenommen
meiner meinung nach ist dies ein
illegaler weg währenddessen gehen die
türkischen vergeltungsangriffe in der
syrischen provinz idlib weiter man habe
unter anderem zwei syrische kampfjets
abgeschossen so das
verteidigungsministerium in ankara
niemand sollte daran zweifeln wenn
angriffe auf unsere truppen und
beobachtungsposten stattfinden werden
wir im rahmen der legitimen verteidigung
die heftigste antwort geben an der
grenze die lage unverändert die
flüchtlinge suchen ihren weg nach europa
da fragen wir nach bei unserem
korrespondenten stefan leifert in
brüssel und jörg brase der vor ort im
türkisch griechischen grenzgebiet ist ja
wie erleben sie die situation dort
ja es ist wirklich unglaublich also auch
jetzt nach einbruch der dunkelheit und
das ist wirklich bitter kalt hier kommen
immer noch große gruppen von flüchtlinge
die hier richtung grenze ziehen ungefähr
einen kilometer hinter mir
wir sehen familien mit kleinen kindern
mit babys beladen
mit rollkoffern mit taschen einige
erzählen uns dass sie teilweise schon
seit jahren in der türkei leben ihre
kinder gehen hier zur schule
sie sprechen fließend türkisch doch sie
haben alles aufgegeben als sie hörten
dass die grenze offen ist und sie
versuchen es nach europa zu kommen nur
ganz wenige kommen von der anderen seite
jetzt in der nacht richtung grenzort sie
erzählen uns von schlimmen zuständen
dort von tausenden von menschen die
nacht im freien verbringen müssen nur
wenige haben das geld um sich im
grenzort eine unterkunft zu leisten doch
auch die haben uns gesagt wir kommen
morgen wieder wir wollen es erneut
versuchen das heißt der druck richtung
europa richtung griechische grenze hier
der bleibt bestehen
eine verzweifelte situation also an der
griechischen grenze
da muss die eu doch reagieren stefan ja
die nervosität hier in brüssel dies mit
händen zu greifen dass ich jetzt hier
eine krise anbahnt in ähnlichen
dimensionen wie die eu dass 2015 schon
erlebt hat auf allen ebenen ist die eu
krisen und telefondiplomatie deswegen
auch am wochenende hochgefahren worden
die kommissionspräsidentin hat mit dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan
telefoniert die staats und
regierungschefs untereinander ergebnis
ist jetzt erst einmal dass es in der
nächsten woche zwei sondertreffen gibt 1
der eu-innenminister und 1 der
europäischen außenminister
die überlegungen die gerade stattfinden
gehen jetzt in zwei richtungen das eine
ist möglichst schnelle und
unkomplizierte hilfe für den
griechischen grenzschutz die
grenzschutzagentur frontex ist unterwegs
an die griechisch türkische grenze mit
schiffen aber auch mit sehr viel
personal und das zweite was überlegt
wird ist wie man dem türkischen
präsidenten möglichst schnell vor allem
finanzielle hilfe anbieten kann
um der lage und den flüchtlingen in
seinem land irgendwie herr zu werden
aber die bereitschaft dazu ist unter den
unterschiedlichen eu mitgliedstaaten
sehr unterschiedlich ausgeprägt für
viele hier in brüssel ist das was gerade
passiert ein déjà vu nach einer phase
der entspannung ist die migrations krise
jetzt mit voller wucht zurück auf der
europäischen agenda
danke stefan leifert nach brüssel danke
jörg brase in die türkei im kampf um die
präsidentschaftskandidatur der us
demokraten hat sich ex vizepräsident joe
biden überraschend zurückgemeldet
nach drei niederlagen gewann er
south carolina seine erste vorwahl und
zwar deutlich vor dem bisherigen
favoriten bernie sanders
nun richten sich alle augen auf den
sogenannten super dienstag den denn
übermorgen wählen gleich 14
bundesstaaten auf einmal dann wird auch
milliardär mike bloomberg erstmals
antreten
wie groß ist der wille zur macht in der
linkspartei
die parteiführung will an die regierung
auch im bund doch teile der basis sehen
sich eher in der opposition eine
strategiekonferenz dieses wochenende in
kassel suchte nach antworten cornelia
schiemenz es geht bei den linken an
diesem wochenende fiel um
regierungsverantwortung
da darf auch er bodo ramelow nicht
fehlen und er hat einen rat an seine
partei die so gerne bis aufs messer
streitet dazu ermuntern mehr das wofür
wir sind zu buchstabieren nicht wogegen
wir sind die linke sucht ihren kompass
zwei tage lang in kassel zentrale frage
wie lässt sich eine mehrheit links der
union erzielen ohne die eigene linke
identität zu verlieren und das bedeutet
er ganz klar keine kriegseinsätze keine
aufrüstung keine privatisierung kein
sozialabbau die parteispitze will auch
im bund an die macht und den
kapitalismus überwinden
doch in kassel wird klar an der basis
gibt es viel widerstand
ich bin der meinung die linke sollte
sich verstehen an seiten der sozialen
bewegungen und an der seite der
gewerkschaften und deren anliegen ins
parlament tragen weniger als und sich
gedanken um die regierung zu machen
sondern das wofür wir häufig gewählt
worden nämlich soziale opposition zu
sein und den regierenden er auf die
finger zu schauen als selber mitzumachen
bodo ramelow ist nach einer stunde
wieder verschwunden gespräche führen
am mittwoch stellt er sich erneut zur
wahl für das amt des ministerpräsidenten
von thüringen
deutschland ist nach einschätzung von
finanzminister scholz für den kampf
gegen die wirtschaftlichen folgen des
corona virus gewappnet der welt am
sonntag sagte er die mittel für ein
entsprechendes konjunkturprogramm sein
da in deutschland gibt es nach angaben
des robert koch instituts
zwischen 129 infizierte im besonders
betroffenen kreis heinsberg in
nordrhein-westfalen endete für mehrere
hundert bewohner die häusliche
quarantäne
bei der berlinale hat die jury das
iranische drama es gibt kein böses mit
dem goldenen bären ausgezeichnet den
preis für den besten film
allerdings fand die verleihung ohne den
regisseur statt
mohammad rasoulof darf nicht ausreisen
er kritisiert mit seinen film das
iranische regime beste darstellerin
wurde paula beer sie erhielt den
silbernen bären für ihre rolle in undine
beide filme sind zdf-koproduktion ja wir
kommen zum sport und da ist leider von
sehr unschönen szenen zu berichten
arbeiten die einhellige empörung über
hetz plakate gestern in hoffenheim zeigt
keine wirkung auch heute beim 2 2
zwischen union berlin und dem vfl
wolfsburg sorgen unbelehrbare sogenannte
fans auf den tribünen für zwei
spielunterbrechungen die fortsetzung der
machtprobe zwischen fans und deutschen
fußball-bund nach erneuten
geschmacklosen schmähungen gegen dietmar
hopp steht das spiel von union berlin
gegen wolfsburg kurz vor dem abbruch
dabei mangelte es nach dem vorfall von
gestern in hoffenheim nicht an klaren
worten das ist eigentlich nicht zu
entschuldigen was dort in der kurve
passiert ist das ist das ganz hässliche
gesicht von bayern münchen nach den
wiederholten beleidigungen gegen
hoffenheims mäzen dietmar hopp aber auch
rassistischen vorfällen scheint das fass
überzulaufen die heizspirale in den
stadien dreht sich immer weiter
der dfb ist gefordert irgendwo sind die
grenzen um wenn man weiß welche gruppen
das welche dinge vor hat dann muss nur
die hat ausschließen
und leider dann auch gruppenweise bist
du bereit es geht nicht mehr anders die
zeichen im deutschen fußball stehen wohl
eher auf konfrontation statt auf dialog
rb leipzig hat nach dem 1 2 1 im zweiten
sonntagsspiel gegen bayer leverkusen nun
drei punkte rückstand auf bayern münchen
immerhin zu gewinnen zum abschluss der
bahnrad-wm im keirin ihr drittes gold
skispringer karl geiger holt den lacht
die seinen vierten weltcup saisonsieg
und bobpilot francesco friedrich
schreibt mit seinen 3
anschiebern in altenberg sportgeschichte
das neunte wm gold seiner karriere
vor den beiden anderen deutschen bobs
und das zdf trauert um eberhard
figgemeier einen geschätzten und hoch
angesehenen kollegen dennis
eiskunstlaufen fußball waren seine
passion die größte und schwierigste
aufgabe bewältigte eberhard figgemeier
bei der katastrophe 1985 im brüsseler
heysel-stadion in der vergangenen nacht
ist er mit 73 jahren gestorben
ja die sind trocken bleibt noch das
wetter am vormittag im nordosten letzte
schauer ab mittag regnet es dann im
westen und im südwesten dazwischen ist
es freundlich und trocken bei 7 bis 12
grad
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
21 uhr 45 und hier ist morgen christian
sievers für sie da ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen sonntagabend und
empfehle ihnen jetzt berlin direkt und
theo koll